Oh surrender oh hey everybody my name is
John Luke and i'm joined by jake jake
how is it going it's going great because
we just got to new mass spec video go to
the story trailer and one is an in drama
initiative video yeah there's a lot to
break down on this starting right here
this is the new earth that the Andromeda
initiative at least the human side of
the Andromeda initiative is trying to
find yeah they're calling it habitat 7
and it is a golden planet which if
you're unfamiliar with the term it means
that it is perfect for human life it it
fills that golden ratio yeah although i
do question what is happening above the
planet this weird threaded goo looking
stuff you see that a lot in the trailer
it seems to be related to the main
villain who will see in a moment and
this is the Hyperion right here he's
referring to 20,000 people of boards but
guessing this is where all of the people
are basically incredibly oh alright so
right here we have the first look at the
villain ship kind of has a board vibe in
terms of aesthetics and color I dig it
get on sat of you they've got a Finnegan
and we think this is the pilot in an
earlier Andromeda initiative video they
kind of showed the tempest and it was
voiced by we think of silurian yeah I'm
excited to have another silurian squad
member i always thought they were one of
the more under appreciated racism aspect
examining room so here is our con the
main villain getting a real starin vibe
off this guy seems like he'll be being
antagonist for at least this first game
who knows what the larger story will be
yeah it seems like there's going to be a
bigger threat but it seems for at least
this first part we're going to be
worrying about him a lot yeah and I hope
that like Farrah knee has a little bit
more to him it's not just black and
white sure we've been outplayed the
Archon is a master we're about to change
and here we go this is this is the shot
right yeah this is where we kind of get
introduced to two new characters we're
familiar with the krogan we've seen the
crow game before and of course that's pd
at the ends but to the right of writer
is Cora Harper and then to the left is
Liam Kosta both our new squad members
and i'm going to guess they are going to
start in your squad right at the
beginning yes
okay so this here is the new alien race
there presumably their home world or a
planted to theirs i love the look of
this planet although like flora and
fauna looks yeah I'm d'architecture to
back there looks pretty cool yeah I'm
really hoping this is a citadel style
planet where I can just walk around and
talk to people and fill my codex full of
entries all I want here's a good close
up shot get the scouter get garrison
scatter back in I like that yeah it's a
really cool design yeah and they got
both male and female races which mass
spec notoriously doesn't really do that
yeah the times they just skip out on one
find them justice I don't need an army
that's gotta produce this line right
here is just ripped straight out of a
the first Avengers movie which I don't
know I like the line I like provide do
mm-hmm and then here we get to see the
some romance yeah some romance options
I like this shot here with me is like oh
that's so good you see again there's
there's all the goo seems like it's
almost just like slowly consuming
everything I bet that might be the
greater threat been waiting six hundred
you
so there's also a trailer on the
Andromeda initiative page that goes into
more detail on the squad members that we
saw in this trailer typically the human
ones was it going to human ones narrated
by Harper so here we see Alec Ryder the
protagonist dad as you can see this is
one of the first times we've seen him
without a helmet and in case you're
wondering and we've known the Toronto
but it's voiced by the same person new
voice mr. Krabs in that little text
bubble over there if you had glasses on
and if you were paying enough attention
it kind of explains moves back story
some of it we already know however it
seems like he's been a huge part of
humanity's exploration into space he was
part of the first contact where he did
that first mass relay jump where he met
batarians and now I think he's on his
final expedition to Andromeda here here
we get to see a little bit more of Liam
he is the human security and crisis
response specialist he seems to be kind
of bored the optimist of the group and
finally we get a look at the Ryder twin
so oddly enough that trailer we saw
didn't have femme writer at all we just
thought we just saw the male writer but
those little BIOS going a little bit
more with them but what's interesting is
if you noticed there's Scott writer and
Sarah rider so they actually have names
I'm not sure how it's going to work in a
game i'm not sure we can be able to
rename whichever one you choose and then
the other sibling will keep that name or
if you will be Scott writer if your mail
and you'll be Sarah writer if you're
female I would assume they let you
change the name for the one who picked
and I would assume so has that name I
would assume so so here we get Korra
Harper herself she might be the most
interesting so far at least what we get
from this trailer so the bio talks about
how she is the second in command and the
successor for the Pathfinder you're the
one who gets to be the Pathfinder in the
game so obviously something happens
going to be some tension is going to be
some tension but clearly they release
that tension later as we saw in the
trade off the air gets really another
interesting thing to you found about her
was that she shared the last name with
an interesting character yeah the mass
effect trilogy yeah the elusive man's
real name is Jack Harper no idea this
that could be a complete coincidence it
doesn't seem like coincidence to me ha
who knows but that could be something to
think about I mean there's always kind
of been this idea that maybe the service
is somehow tied to this
they talk a lot about how this thing is
privately funded yeah and server says a
lot of shell organizations that they
used to fund money into some people
don't necessarily know it through
Cerberus so I could absolutely see you
finding out like Cerberus helped fund
this whole I think it was going to play
a role in this game at some point
somehow yeah here they're talking about
Sam the artificial intelligence that is
like murali linked to all your squad
members which is I guess how they
justify you being able to like talk to
them and where you are interestingly in
the bio they say Sam was created by dr.
Ellen Ryder who is presumably their mom
I'd guess so yeah but we don't ever see
her they never mentioned her doesn't
seem like she's a part of the initiative
at least like with them so maybe
something happen to her maybe she did
behind who knows and that about covers
it and if you want to see more mass
effect and dramatist stuff from us me
and Jacob done a couple other trailer
breakdowns we also have a seven biggest
changes that are going to be coming to
Maastricht and dramas to go check that
video out and we are looking forward to
seeing the game on march 21st
[Music]